[MUSIC]
My grandfather always told me,
don't bet the ranch.
This is a family entity, there are other
members of your family that rely upon it,
that's something I take very seriously.
So that means you have to be making
decisions a little more conservatively,
you have to be more
patient in your decisions.
And for him that meant don't bet
the ranch, don't make too big of a play.
Yet I also think about it today,
I'm 38, and in looking at the next
25 years plus of my career, and I want to
make sure that I'm in a position and
leading an organization
that I'm passionate about.
My name is Ryan O'Melveny Wilson.
I am the Chief Marketing and
Strategy Officer of Lawry's Restaurants,
Incorporated.
I graduated from
the GSB Sloan Class of 2018.
I'm fourth generation in the business.
Lawry, the namesake, was Lawrence Frank,
my great grandfather.
When we opened the restaurant, actually
in the development of the concept,
my great grandfather wanted to
serve a single entree, that's it.
He wanted to be one item, and that meal
stayed the same until probably the mid
80s, when the first change we
incorporated on this menu was
the inclusion of sour
cream on the baked potato.
[MUSIC]
Today we're at
Lawry's The Prime Rib Beverly Hills.
It's in the midst of a whole reconcepting,
revitalization of business.
That business opportunity challenge, I've
taken a tremendous amount of learnings
from my coursework at Stanford
into how to rebuild a business and
how to make it much more nimble and lean.
And that's something I'm
really excited about.
[MUSIC]
I think, particularly against
the backdrop of Silicon Valley,
where everyone's expectation
is something new and
different and a disruptive workplace, a
disruptive company, a disruptive product.
There's something about coming and
working for
an established brand that I think
is forgotten in that environment.
[MUSIC]
And so when I hear that adage of fail
fast, I think about the idea of constantly
making evolutions and
progress in a restaurant.
Every single day we need to be making some
subtle change that is making the dining
experience better.
And so fail fast sounds really scary when
you look at it on a big picture, and
that's something we don't do.
We take great steps to mitigate
against that big picture risk.
But on a small scale,
we're always looking to make improvements,
whether it's a garnish or
a presentation, or trying new salad or
a slight change in our steps of service or
a new menu presentation.
I want our organization to always be
willing to make those little changes.
So one of the great things
about the restaurant business,
it's one of the few businesses that
has such a tight feedback loop.
I serve you a salad, I'm going to know
within the first couple of bites if that
salad is proper temperature,
is served at the proper time,
that the flavor profile's right.
I can know very immediately from
your facial reaction, frankly.
I know that quality is not easy.
And yet I think quality is ultimately
a differentiator, and I'm not looking for
the easy fixes.
I'm looking for
the quality I'm looking for
things that are going to be attractive to
a specific palate, a specific consumer.
And to me that's a defining
piece of advice and
a defining element of how I make
decisions as an entrepreneur.
And for me, and I want to be in a position
where I'm creating new things, and
that's speaking to my own motivations.
And I think it's really important
to express those needs and
desires rather than just be a slave,
if you will, to what the expectations are.
I'm passionate about the food.
And in a family business I think it's okay
to be explicit about what your motivations
are and what you're passionate about.
I think in the end that's going to
make you more comfortable and
more confident and
being in this role for a career.
I'm not going anywhere, right?
I'm not looking to jump in 2 years
when the next best offer comes around,
I'm looking at the next 30 to 40 years.
[MUSIC]